Typing in long directory and
file names is a big, boring pain and
nobody likes doing it.
One way you can avoid running out of
fingers is to use tab completion.
It works pretty much the same
as tab completion for commands.
As you're typing a command or
file path, just hit the tab key.
If you've typed enough to
distinguish a single command or
a single file, the shell will
automatically complete it.
Otherwise it will go beep.
Then if you press tab again it'll list
all of the possible completions for
what you've typed.
Experienced Shell users use
tab completion all the time
almost without thinking about it.
Try it out.
You can actually use it to navigate
all around the directory structure
without ever using the CD at all.